went to the boys love section in a manga
store here and i got so many looks
all the women were like what the [ __ ] is
it yeah i get that too every time anki
like wants to go buy like kingdom hearts
i'm just like i i shouldn't be here i'm
getting really weird
like i'm not welcome like i'm yeah i'm
in danger here i i sometimes get that
just from walking down like autumn road
in ikebukuro
because like you know otomero obviously
as the name implies like it's for like
fujioshi's and just like
girls who are into that kind of stuff
yeah and i'm just like i'm just get off
this public
and and there are just like some i i i
legit get stares from like some
other like fujioshi's who are just like
you don't belong here
what are you doing here you're a man you
cis white male he's a
male he's amazing enjoying my gay porn
yeah
get out of here i'm just like it's a
public road no male's allowed in gay
porn
no no no you actually went to the
uh the yowie cafe right the boys
how was it did you enjoy it it was
interesting they were all wearing masks
oh yeah we could only see if you if you
don't know i mean i might as well plug
my own video go and watch the the yowie
cafe video
it's great it's where they basically do
they really rush
like everything whole throughout the
whole episode again
yeah i was like you're so red because
it's like okay basically they pretty
much act bl scenes in front of you
yeah yeah i haven't but i watched these
videos
like it's as like a western person it
like doesn't like work in my brain yeah
this thing is so like i mean i had to i
had to translate some of the like
in aki's video because they're doing it
in japanese yeah and aki's like i don't
know what they're saying so can you
translate this
and just sitting there and just watching
like the video of your skits i'm just
like
oh no yeah i watch an ackee's video too
right yeah i'm just like oh my god i
can't i can't
we turned up and they were like so what
do you want us to do and i'm like like
just do your thing
what do you normally do just like just
do it just do it we'll blur it out like
just do it
and they just were like oh we can do
like a rice thing and i'm like sure and
they start doing it and i'm like oh my
god like they're doing this
and i feel so bad for you because you
know aggie was with her female friends
so like
[Applause]
can you give us the like yeah and i'm
like okay raining out of ten
and then they did the thing where
they're like what's the thing when you
put your arm
yeah and then i was like and they did
that and i'm like yeah this is cool and
all but uh can you like can one of you
hold my kermit the doll
like kermit the frog i brought my kermit
the frog with me
and i was like i was like hey maybe
because you like it's like you know
it's a little joke on my channel like
hey maybe could you do something the guy
just [ __ ] grabs it
shoves his hand inside kermit he's like
we're gonna do a scene with kermit
i didn't even get to say anything he's
[ __ ]
he was like what do you want me to do
with it i'm like two times you've
already
oh my god this is so embarrassing
because like there's like two cameras on
me everyone's like is this what you
wanted connor just what you this is the
footage you wanted i'm
i guess this like what i wanted like oh
my god one of the hardest videos to sit
through
there's just something about seeing you
know real people acting
like they just like anime characters you
know in anime
you know it's it's like it just seems
normal but when you see real live people
doing it sometimes going to a maid cafe
is just like
don't talk about me caffeine i i went
once and once was all i needed
which one i went to uh it was the one in
akiba
yeah yeah because my friend who's like a
huge fan of maid cafes was like you've
never been to a maid cafe
we should go it's like i know the best
one i'm like all right and i went and uh
man i've i've never been more
disappointed in a two thousand yen on
race in my life i'm just like this thing
cost 2 000 yen
and it took like 45 minutes to come out
and it's like cold
and they put the spell on it right yeah
and they put a spell on it and i'm like
you could yeah they did they do like the
muay morikun spell and they they force
you to say it as well
i don't need a spell i need a microwave
spell isn't doing anything but making it
cold
the most awkward experience in my life
was having to do that
i was dressed as a maid and i had to
idea at the end
yeah and there was like 10 businessmen
and they were like they were all just
just not saying anything not not
laughing
whenever i did anything they were just
staring and it was horrible because
these girls were really awkward as me
yeah it's just to be like wow but they
were like
i guess and then i had to draw
on the omu rice i drew sanic
[Laughter]
with ketchup yeah with ketchup and it
was like defusing a bomb it was so
tense in that room everyone everyone was
silent while i was doing it
and i'm like sweating i'm like yeah i'm
like can we can someone break the
silence do something funny
whenever i made a joke obviously because
none of them could speak english they
were just like
just just to break the silence you
should just like under your breath just
be like
so you like made cafes uh my friend that
made cafe so
i i don't go there by myself no i'm not
that like avid like a religious
yeah yeah because there are some
religious people yeah there's people
that go to every maid cafe and just rate
every maid cafe
like this oh this maid was pretty cute
oh she said mo mo kind the way i wanted
to play it
the way i wanted to hear it different